who moved my cheese
an amazing way to deal with change in
your work and in your life
who moved my cheese is a simple parable
that reveals profound truths about
change
it is an amusing and enlightening story
of four characters who live in a maze
and look for cheese to nourish them and
make them happy
two are mice named sniff and scurry
and two are little people beings the
size of mice who look and act a lot like
people
their names are ham and ha
cheese is a metaphor for what you want
to have in life whether it's a good job
a loving relationship money a possession
good health or spiritual peace of mind
and the maze is where you look for what
you want the organization you work in or
the family or community you live in
in the story the characters are faced
with unexpected change
eventually one of them deals with it
successfully and writes what he has
learned from his experience on the maze
walls
when you come to see the handwriting on
the wall you can discover for yourself
how to deal with change so that you can
enjoy less stress and more success
however you define it in your work and
in your life
written for all ages this story takes
less than an hour to read but its unique
insights can last for a lifetime
parts of all of us
the simple and the complex the four
imaginary characters depicted in this
story
the mice sniff and scurry and the little
people him and ha are intended to
represent the simple and the complex
parts of ourselves regardless of our age
gender race or nationality
sometimes we may act like sniff
who sniffs out change early or scurry
who scurries into action or him who
denies and resists change as he fears it
will lead to something worse or ha who
learns to adapt in time when he sees
changing can lead to something better
whatever parts of us we choose to use we
all share something in common a need to
find our way in the maze and succeed in
changing times
a gathering
chicago
one sunny sunday in chicago
several former classmates who were good
friends in school gathered for lunch
having attended their high school
reunion the night before
they wanted to hear more about what was
happening in each other's lives
after a good deal of kidding and a good
meal they settled into an interesting
conversation
angela who had been one of the most
popular people in the class said life
sure turned out differently than i
thought it would when we were in
school a lot has changed
it certainly has nathan echoed
they knew he had gone into his family's
business which had operated pretty much
the same and had been a part of the
local community for as long as they
could remember so they were surprised
when he seemed concerned
he asked but have you noticed how we
don't want to change when things change
carlos said i guess we resist changing
because we're afraid of change
carlos you were captain of the football
team jessica said
i never thought i'd hear you say
anything about being afraid
they all laughed as they realized that
although they had gone off in different
directions from working at home to
managing companies they were
experiencing similar feelings
everyone was trying to cope with the
unexpected changes that were happening
to them in recent years
and most admitted that they did not know
a good way to handle them
then michael said i used to be afraid of
change
when a big change came along in our
business we didn't know what to do
so we didn't adjust and we almost lost
it
that is he continued until i heard a
funny little story that changed
everything
how so
nathan asked
well the story changed the way i looked
at change from losing something to
gaining something and it showed me how
to do it
after that things quickly improved at
work and in my life
at first i was annoyed with the obvious
simplicity of the story because it
sounded like something we might have
been told in school
then i realized i was really annoyed
with myself for not seeing the obvious
and doing what works when things change
when i realized the four characters in
the story represented the various parts
of myself i decided who i wanted to act
like and i changed
later i passed the story on to some
people in our company and they passed it
on to others and soon our business did
much better because most of us adapted
to change better
and like me many people said it helped
them in their personal lives
however there were a few people who said
they got nothing out of it
they either knew the lessons and were
already living them or more commonly
they thought they already knew
everything and didn't want to learn
they couldn't see why so many others
were benefiting from it
when one of our senior executives who
was having difficulty adapting said the
story was a waste of time other people
kitted him saying they knew which
character he was in the story meaning
the one who learned nothing new and did
not
change what's the story
angela asked
it's called
who moved my cheese
the group left
i think i like it already carlos said
would you tell us the story
maybe we can get something from it
sure michael replied
i'd be happy to it doesn't take long
and so he began
who moved my cheese
the story unce long ago in a land far
away there lived four little characters
who ran through a maze looking for
cheese to nourish them and make them
happy
two were mice named sniff and scurry and
two were little people
beings who were as small as mice but who
looked and acted a lot like people today
their names were hem and ah
due to their small size it would be easy
not to notice what the four of them were
doing but if you look closely enough you
could discover the most amazing things
every day the mice and the little people
spent time in the maze looking for their
own special cheese
the mice
sniff and scurry possessing simple
brains and good instincts searched for
the hard nibbling cheese they liked as
mice often do
the two little people hem and ha use
their complex brains phil ed with many
beliefs and emotions to search for a
very different kind of cheese
with a capital c which they believed
would make them feel happy and
successful
as different as the mice and little
people were they shared something in
common every morning they each put on
their jogging suits and running shoes
left their little homes and raced out
into the maze looking for their favorite
cheese
the maize was a labyrinth of corridors
and chambers some containing delicious
cheese
but there were also dark corners and
blind alleys leading nowhere
it was an easy place for anyone to get
lost
however for those who found their way
the maze held secrets that let them
enjoy a better life
the mice sniff and scurry used the
simple trial and error method of finding
cheese
they ran down one corridor and if it
proved empty they turned and ran down
another
they remembered the corridors that held
no cheese and quickly went into new
areas
sniff would smell out the general
direction of the cheese using his great
nose and scurry would race ahead
they got lost as you might expect went
off in the wrong direction and often
bumped into walls
but after a while they found their way
like the mice the two little people him
and hall also used their ability to
think and learn from their past
experiences
however they relied on their complex
brains to develop more sophisticated
methods of finding cheese
sometimes they did well but at other
times their powerful human beliefs end
emotions took over and clouded the way
they looked at things
it made life in the maze more
complicated and challenging
nonetheless sniff scurry him and hall
discovered in their own way what they
were looking for
they each found their own kind of cheese
one day at the end of one of the
corridors in chi station c
every morning after that the mice and
the little people dressed in their
running gear and headed over to cheese
station c
it wasn't long before they each
established their own routine
sniff and scurry continued to wake early
every day and race through the maze
always following the same route
when they arrived at their destination
the mice took off their running shoes
tied them together and hung them around
their necks so they could get to them
quickly whenever they needed them again
then they enjoyed the cheese
in the beginning ham and hall also raced
toward cheese station see every morning
to enjoy the tasty new morsels that
awaited them
but after a while a different routine
set in for the little people
ham and hall woke each day a little
later dressed a little slower and walked
to cheese station c
after all they knew where the cheese was
now and how to get there
they had no idea where the cheese came
from or who put it there
they just assumed it would be there
as soon as ham and her arrived at chi
station see each morning they settled in
and made themselves at home
they hung up their jogging suits put
away their running shoes and put on
their slippers
they were becoming very comfortable now
that they had found the cheese
this is great ham said
there's enough cheese here to last us
forever
the little people felt happy and
successful and thought they were now
secure
it wasn't long before ham and hor
regarded the cheese they found a cheese
station see as their cheese
it was such a large store of cheese that
they eventually moved their homes to be
closer to it and built a social life
around it
to make themselves feel more at home him
and how decorated the walls with sayings
and even drew pictures of cheese around
them which made them smile
one read
sometimes ham and hoe would take their
friends by to see their pile of cheese
at cheese station c and point to it with
pride saying pretty nice cheese hub
sometimes they shared it with their
friends and sometimes they didn't
we deserve this cheese hem said
we certainly had to work long and hard
enough to find it
he picked up a nice fresh piece and ate
it
afterward him fell asleep as he often
did
every night the little people would
waddle home full of cheese and every
morning they would confidently return
for more
this went on for quite some time
after a while hems and haas confidence
grew into the arrogance of success
soon they became so comfortable they
didn't even notice what was happening
as time went on
sniff and scurry continued their routine
they arrived early each morning and
sniffed and scratched and scurried
around cheese station sea inspecting the
area to see if there had been any
changes from the day before
then they would sit down to nibble on
the cheese
one morning they arrived at chi station
c and discovered there was no cheese
they weren't surprised
since sniff and scurry had noticed the
supply of cheese had been getting
smaller every day they were prepared for
the inevitable and knew instinctively
what to do
they looked at each other removed the
running shoes they had tied together and
hung conveniently around
someday and living in a cozy cottage on
cheddar lane
to him cheese was becoming a big cheese
in charge of others and
harder at the moment
things are changing around
to be out on an adventure in the maze
and to find fresh new cheese
he could almost taste it
the more clearly ha saw the image of
himself finding and enjoying the new
cheese the more he saw himself leaving
cheese station c
let's go he exclaimed all of a sudden
no hem quickly responded
i like it here
it's comfortable
it's what i know
besides it's dangerous out there no it
isn't all argued
we've run through many parts of the maze
before and we can do it again
i'm getting too old for that hem said
and i'm afraid i'm not interested in
getting lost and making a fool of myself
are you
with that
host's fear of failing returned in his
hope of finding new cheese faded
so every day the little people continued
to do what they had done before
they went to cheese station c found no
cheese and returned home carrying their
worries and frustrations with them
they tried to deny what was happening
but found it harder to get to sleep had
less energy the next day and were
becoming irritable
their homes were not the nurturing
places they once were
the little people had difficulty
sleeping and were having nightmares
about not finding any cheese
but ham and hoss still returned to
cheese station c and waited there every
day
hem said you know if we just work harder
we all find that nothing has really
changed that much
the cheese is probably nearby
maybe they just hit it behind the wall
the next day
ham and hull returned with tools
hem held the chisel while hall banged on
the hammer until they made a hole in the
wall of cheese station c
they peered inside but found no cheese
they were disappointed but believed they
could solve the problem
so they started earlier stayed longer
and worked harder
but after a while all they had was a
large hole in the wall all was beginning
to realize the difference between
activity and productivity
maybe hem said we should just sit here
and see what happens
sooner or
home wanted to l that
so each day he went home to rest and
returned
reluctantly with him to cheese station
see
but cheese never reappeared
by now the little people were growing
weak from hunger and stress
hall was getting tired of just waiting
for their situation to improve
he began to see that the longer they
stayed in their cheeseless situation the
worse off they would be
han knew they were losing their edge
finally one day ha began laughing at
himself
ha ha look at us
we keep doing the same things over and
over again and wonder why things don't
get better
if this wasn't so ridiculous it would be
even funnier
i did not like the idea of having to run
through the maze again because he knew
he would get lost and have no idea where
he would find any cheese
but he had to laugh at his folly when he
saw what his fear was doing to him
he asked him where did we put our
running shoes
it took a long time to find them because
they had put everything away when they
found their cheese at cheese station sea
thinking they wouldn't be needing them
anymore as hem saw his friend getting
into his running gear he said you're not
really going out into the maze again are
you
why don't you just wait here with me
until they put the cheese back
because you just don't get it ha said
i didn't want to see it either but now i
realize they're never going to put
yesterday's cheese back
it's time to find new cheese
hem argued but what if there is no
cheese out there
or even if there is what if you don't
find it
i don't know ha said
he had asked himself those same
questions too many times and felt the
fears again that kept him where he was
he asked himself where am i more likely
to find cheese here or in the maze
he painted a picture in his mind
he saw himself venturing out into the
maze with a smile on his face
while this picture surprised him it made
him feel good
he saw himself getting lost now and then
in the maze but felt confident he would
eventually find new cheese out there and
all the good things that came with it
he gathered his courage
then he used his imagination to paint
the most believable picture he could
with the most realistic details of him
finding and enjoying the taste of new
cheese
he saw himself eating swiss cheese with
holes in it bright orange cheddar and
american cheeses italian mozzarella and
wonderfully soft french camembert cheese
a and d
then he heard him say something and
realized they were still a cheese
station see
ha said sometimes ham things change and
they are never the same again
this looks like one of those times
that's life
life moves on
and so should we
i looked at his emaciated companion and
tried to talk sense to him but hem's
fear had turned into anger and he
wouldn't listen
ha didn't mean to be rude to his friend
but he had to laugh at how sill why they
both looked
as how prepared to leave he started to
feel more alive knowing that he was
finally able to laugh at himself let go
and move on
hall laughed and announced it's
maze time
hen didn't laugh and he didn't respond
paul picked up a small sharp rock and
wrote a serious thought on the wall for
him to think about
as was his custom
ha even drew a picture of cheese around
it hoping it would help him to smile
lighten up and go after the new cheese
but him didn't want to see it
it read
then hoss stuck his head out and peered
anxiously into the maze
he thought about how he'd gotten himself
into this cheeseless situation
he had believed that there may not be
any cheese in the maze or he may not
find it
such fearful beliefs were immobilizing
and killing him
ha smiled
he knew him was wondering
who moved my cheese but hull was
wondering why didn't i get up and move
with the cheese sooner
as he started out into the maze hull
looked back to where he had come from
and felt its comfort
he could feel himself being drawn back
into familiar territory even though he
hadn't found cheese here for some time
paul became more anxious and wondered if
he really wanted to go out into the maze
he wrote a saying on the wall ahead of
him and stared at it for some time
he thought about it he knew sometimes
some fear can be good
when you are afraid things are going to
get worse if you don't do something it
can prompt you into action
but it is not good when you are so
afraid that it keeps you from doing
anything
he looked to his right to the part of
the maze where he had never been and
felt the fear
then he took a deep breath turned right
into the maze and jogged slowly into the
unknown
as he tried to find his way
all worried at first that he might have
waited too long in chi station c
he hadn't had any cheese for so long
that he was now weak
it took him longer and it was more
painful than usual to get through the
maze he decided that if he ever got the
chance again he would get out of his
comfort zone and adapt to change sooner
it would make things easier
then ha smiled a weak smile as he
thought better late than never during
the next several days i found a little
cheese here and there but nothing that
lasted very long
he had hoped to find enough cheese to
take some back to him and encourage him
to come out into the maze
but ha didn't feel confident enough yet
he had to admit he found it confusing in
the maze
things seemed to have changed since the
last time he was out here
just when he thought he was getting
ahead he would get lost in the corridors
it seemed his progress was two steps
forward and one step backward
it was a challenge but he had to admit
that being back in the maze hunting for
cheese wasn't nearly as bad as he feared
it might be
as time went on he began to wonder if it
was realistic for him to expect to find
new cheese
he wondered if he had bitten off more
than he could chew
then he laughed realizing that he had
nothing to chew on at that moment
whenever he started to get discouraged
he reminded himself that what he was
doing as uncomfortable as it was at the
moment was in reality much better than
staying in the cheeseless situation
he was taking control rather than simply
letting things happen to him then he
reminded himself if sniff and scurry
could move on so could he
later as hal looked back on things he
realized that the cheese at cheese
station see had not just disappeared
overnight as he had once believed
the amount of cheese that had been there
toward the end had been getting smaller
and what was left had grown old
it didn't taste as good
mold may even have begun to grow on the
old cheese although he hadn't noticed it
he had to admit however that if he had
wanted to he probably could have seen
what was coming
but he didn't
ha now realized that the change probably
would not have taken him by surprise if
he had been watching what was happening
all along and if he had anticipated
change
maybe that's what sniff and scurry had
been doing
he decided he would stay more alert from
now on
he would expect change to happen and
look for it
he would trust his basic instincts to
sense when change was going to occur and
be ready to adapt to it
he stopped for a rest and wrote on the
wall of the maze sometime later after
not finding cheese for what seemed like
a long time all finally came across a
huge cheese station which looked
promising
when he went inside however he was most
disappointed to discover that the cheese
station was empty
this empty feeling has happened to me
too often he thought he felt like giving
up
paul was losing his physical strength
he knew he was lost and was afraid he
would not survive
he thought about turning around and
heading back to chi station c
at least if he made it back and him was
still there all wouldn't be alone
then he asked himself the same question
again what would i do if i weren't
afraid
i thought he was past his fear but he
was afraid more often than he liked to
admit even to himself
he wasn't always sure what he was afraid
of but in his weakened condition he knew
now he was simply fearful of going on
alone
didn't know it but he was running behind
because he was still
weighed down by fearful beliefs
paul wondered if him had moved on or if
he was still paralyzed by his own fears
then or remembered the times when he had
felt his best in the maze
it was when he was moving along
he wrote on the wall knowing it was as
much a reminder to himself as it was a
marking for his friend him hopefully to
follow hull looked down the dark
passageway and was aware of his fear
what lay ahead
was it empty
or worse were there dangers lurking
he began to imagine all kinds of
frightening things that could happen to
him
he was scaring himself to death
then he laughed at himself
he realized his fears were making things
worse
so he did what he would do if he weren't
afraid
he moved in a new direction
as he started running down the dark
corridor he began to smile
didn't realize it yet but he was
discovering what nourished his soul
he was letting go and trusting what lay
ahead for him even though he did not
know exactly what it was
to his surprise i started to enjoy
himself more and more
why do i feel so good he wondered
i don't have any cheese and i don't know
where i am going
before long he knew why he felt good
he stopped to write again on the wall
paul realized he had been held captive
by his own fear
moving in a new direction had freed him
now he felt the cool breeze that was
blowing in this part of the maze and it
was refreshing
he took in some deep breaths and felt
invigorated by the movement
once he had gotten past his fear it
turned out to be more enjoyable than he
once believed it could be
i hadn't felt this way for a long time
he had almost forgotten how much fun it
was to go for it
to make things even better
all started to paint a picture in his
mind again
he saw himself in great realistic detail
sitting in the middle of a pile of all
his favorite cheeses from cheddar debris
he saw himself eating the many cheeses
he liked and he enjoyed what he saw
then he imagined how much he would enjoy
all their great tastes
the more clearly he saw the image of
himself enjoying new cheese the more
real and believable it became
he could sense that he was going to find
it
he wrote
i kept thinking about what he could gain
instead of what he was losing
he wondered why he had always thought
that a change would lead to something
worse
now he realized that change could lead
to something better
why didn't i see this before he asked
himself
then he raced through the maze with
greater strength and agility
before long he spotted a cheese station
and became excited as he noticed little
pieces of new cheese near the entrance
they were types of cheese he had never
seen before but they looked great
he tried them and found that they were
delicious
he ate most of the new cheese bits that
were available and put a few in his
pocket to have later and perhaps share
with him
he began to regain his strength
he entered the cheese station with great
excitement
but to his dismay he found it was empty
someone had already been there and had
left only the few bits of new cheese
he realized that if he had moved sooner
he would very likely have found a good
deal of new cheese here
ha decided to go back and see if him was
ready to join him
as he retraced his steps he stopped and
wrote on the wall after a while home
made his way back to cheese station c
and found him
he offered him bits of new cheese but
was turned down
em appreciated his friend's gesture but
said i don't think i would like new
cheese
it's not what i'm used to
i want my own cheese back and i'm not
going to change until i get what i want
i just shook his head in disappointment
and reluctantly went back out on his own
as he returned to the farthest point he
had reached in the maze he missed his
friend but realized he liked what he was
discovering
even before he found what he hoped would
be a great supply of new cheese if ever
he knew that what made him happy wasn't
just having cheese
he was happy when he wasn't being run by
his fear
he liked what he was doing now
knowing this
ha didn't feel as weak as he did when he
stayed in cheese station c with no
cheese
just realizing he was not letting his
fear stop him and knowing that he had
taken a new direction nourished him and
gave him strength
now he felt that it was just a question
of time before he found what he needed
in fact he sensed he had already found
what he was looking for
he smiled as he realized
paul realized again as he had once
before that what you are afraid of is
never as bad as what you imagine
the fear you let build up in your mind
is worse than the situation that
actually exists
he'd been so afraid of never finding new
cheese that he didn't even want to start
looking
but since starting his journey he had
found enough cheese in the corridors to
keep him going
now he looked forward to finding more
just looking ahead was becoming exciting
his old thinking had been clouded by his
worries and fears
he used to think about not having enough
cheese or not having it last as long as
he wanted
he used to think more about what could
go wrong than what could go right
but that had changed in the days since
he had left cheese station c
he used to believe that cheese should
never be moved in that change
wasn't right
now he realized it was natural for
change to continually occur whether you
expect it or not
change could surprise you only if you
didn't expect it and weren't looking for
it
when he realized he had changed his
beliefs he paused to write on the wall i
hadn't found any cheese yet but as he
ran through the maze he thought about
what he had already learned
on now realized that his new beliefs
were encouraging new behaviors
he was behaving differently than when he
kept returning to the same cheeseless
station
he knew that when you change what you
believe you change what you do
you can believe that a change will harm
you and resist it
or you can believe that finding new
cheese will help you and embrace the
change
it all depends on what you choose to
believe
he wrote on the wall
i knew he would be in better shape now
if he had dealt with the change much
sooner and left cheese station c earlier
he would feel stronger in body and
spirit and he could have coped better
with the challenge of finding new cheese
in fact he probably would have found it
by now if he had expected change rather
than wasting time denying that the
change had already taken place
he used his imagination again and saw
himself finding and savoring new cheese
he decided to proceed into the more
unknown parts of the maze and found
little bits of cheese here and there
all began to regain his strength and
confidence
as he thought back on where he had come
from
i was glad he had written on the wall in
many places
he trusted that it would serve as a
marked trail for him to follow through
the maze if he ever chose to leave
cheese station c
i just hoped he was heading in the right
direction
he thought about the possibility that
hem would read the handwriting on the
wall and find his way
he wrote on the wall what he had been
thinking about for some time by now i
had let go of the past and was adapting
to the present
he continued on through the maze with
greater strength and speed
and before long it happened
when it seemed like he had been in the
maze forever his journey or at least
this part of his journey ended quickly
and happily
hal proceeded along a corridor that was
new to him rounded a corner and found
new cheese at cheese station anne
when he went inside he was startled by
what he saw
piled high everywhere was the greatest
supply of cheese he had ever seen
he didn't recognize all
that he saw as some kinds of cheese were
new to him
then he wondered for a moment whether it
was real or just his imagination until
he saw his old friend sniff and scurry
sniff welcomed hall with a knot of his
head and scurry waved his paw
their fat little belly showed that they
had been here for some time
hawk quickly set his hellos and soon
took bites of every one of his favorite
cheeses
he pulled off his shoes tied the laces
together and hung them around his neck
in case he needed them again
sniff and scurry laughed
they nodded their heads in admiration
then hot jumped into the new cheese
when he had eaten his fill he lifted a
piece of fresh cheese and made a toast
hooray for change
as ha enjoyed the new cheese he
reflected on what he had learned
he realized that when he had been afraid
to change he had been holding on to the
illusion of old cheese that was no
longer there
so what was it that made him change
was it the fear of starving to death
ha smiled as he thought it certainly
helped
then he laughed and realized that he had
started to change as soon as he had
learned to laugh at himself and at what
he had been doing wrong
he realized the fastest way to change is
to laugh at your own folly then you can
let go and quickly move on
he knew he had learned something useful
about moving on from his mice friends
sniff and scurry
they kept life simple
they didn't over analyze or over
complicate things
when the situation changed and the
cheese had been moved they changed and
moved with the cheese
he would remember that
had also used his wonderful brain to do
what little people do better than mice
he envisioned himself in realistic
detail finding something better much
better
he reflected on the mistakes he had made
in the past and used them to plan for
his future
he knew that you could learn to deal
with change
you could be more aware of the need to
keep things simple be flexible and move
quickly
you did not need to over complicate
matters or confuse yourself with fearful
beliefs
you could notice when the little changes
began so that you would be better
prepared for the big change that might
be coming
he knew he needed to adapt faster for if
you do not adapt in time you might as
well not adapt at all
he had to admit that the biggest
inhibitor to change lies within yourself
and that nothing gets better until you
change perhaps most importantly he
realized that there is always new cheese
out there whether you recognize it at
the time or not
and that you are rewarded with it when
you go past your fear and enjoy the
adventure
he knew some fear should be respected
as it can keep you out of real danger
but he realized most of his fears were
irrational and had kept him from
changing when he needed to
he didn't like it at the time but he
knew that the change had turned out to
be a blessing in disguise as it led him
to find better cheese
he had even found a better part of
himself
as who recalled what he had learned he
thought about his friend him
he wondered if him had read any of the
sayings ha had written on the wall at
cheese station c and throughout the maze
had him ever decided to let go and move
on
had he ever entered the maze and
discovered what could make his life
better
or was him still hemmed in because he
would not change
i thought about going back again to chi
station see to see if he could find him
assuming that hulk could find his way
back there
if he found him he thought he might be
able to show him how to get out of his
predicament
but whole realized that he had already
tried to get his friend to change
him had to find his own way beyond his
comforts and past his fears
no one else could do it for him or talk
him into it
he somehow had to see the advantage of
changing himself
ha knew he had left a trail for him and
that he could find his way if he could
just read the handwriting on the wall
he went over and wrote down a summary of
what he had learned on the largest wall
of cheese station anne
he drew a large piece of cheese around
all the insights he had become aware of
and smiled as he looked at what he had
learned
paul realized how far he had come since
he had been with him in cheese station c
but knew it would be easy for him to
slip back if he got too comfortable
so each day he inspected cheese station
and to see what the condition of his
cheese was
he was going to do whatever he could to
avoid being surprised by unexpected
change
while ha still had a great supply of
cheese he often went out into the maze
and explored new areas to stay in touch
with what was happening around him
he knew it was safer to be aware of his
real choices than to isolate himself in
his comfort zone
then i heard what he thought was the
sound of movement out in the maze
as the noise grew louder he realized
that someone was coming
could it be that ham was arriving
was he about to turn the corner
off said a little prayer and hoped as he
had many times before that maybe at last
his friend was finally able to
a discussion
later that same day
when michael finished telling the story
he looked around the room and saw his
former classmates smiling at him
several thanked him and said they got a
good deal out of the story
nathan asked the group what would you
think of getting together later and
maybe discussing it
most of them said they would like to
talk about it and so they arranged to
meet later for a drink before dinner
that evening as they gathered in a hotel
lounge they began to kid each other
about finding their cheese and seeing
themselves in the maze
then angela asked the group good
naturally so who were you in the story
sniff scurry him or ha
carlos answered well i was thinking
about that this afternoon
i clearly remember a time before i had
my sporting goods business when i had a
rough encounter with change
i wasn't sniff one didn't sniff out the
situation and see the change early
and i certainly wasn't scary one didn't
go into action immediately
i was more like him who wanted to stay
in familiar territory
the truth is i didn't want to deal with
the change
i didn't even want to see it
michael who felt like no time had passed
since he and carlos were close friends
in school asked what are we talking
about here buddy
carlos said an unexpected change of
jobs michael laughed
you were fired
well let's just say i didn't want to go
out looking for new cheese
i thought i had a good reason why change
shouldn't happen to me
so i was pretty upset at the time
some of their former classmates who had
been quiet in the beginning felt more
comfortable now and spoke up including
frank who had gone into the military
ham reminds me of a friend of mine frank
said
his department was closing down but he
didn't want to see it
they kept relocating his people
we all tried to talk to him about the
many other opportunities that existed in
the company for those who wanted to be
flexible but he didn't think he had to
change
he was the only one who was surprised
when his department closed
now he's having a hard time adjusting to
the change he didn't think should happen
jessica said i didn't think it should
happen to me either but my cheese has
been moved more than once especially in
my personal life but we can get to that
later
many in the group laughed except nathan
maybe that's the whole point nathan said
change happens to all of us
he added i wish my family had heard the
cheese story before this
unfortunately we didn't want to see the
changes coming in our business and now
it's too late we're having to close many
of our stores
that surprised many in the group because
they thought nathan was lucky to be in a
secure business he could depend on year
after year
what happened
jessica wanted to know
our chain of small stores suddenly
became old-fashioned when the mega store
came to town with its huge inventory and
low prices
we just couldn't compete with that
i can see now that instead of being like
sniff and scurry we were like him
we stayed where we were and didn't
change
we tried to ignore what was happening
and now we are in trouble
we could have taken a couple of lessons
from all because we certainly couldn't
laugh at ourselves and change what we
were doing
laura who had become a successful
businesswoman had been listening but had
said very little until now
i thought about the story this afternoon
too
she said
i wondered how i could be more like ha
and see what i'm doing wrong laugh at
myself change and do better
she said i'm curious
how many here are afraid of change
no one responded so she suggested how
about a show of hands
only one hand went up
well it looks like we've got one honest
person in our group she said
and then continued maybe ul like this
next question better
how many here think other people are
afraid of change
practically everyone raised their hands
then they all started laughing
what does that tell us
denial nathan answered
sure michael admitted
sometimes we're not even aware that
we're afraid
i know i wasn't
when i first heard the story i love the
question what would you do if you
weren't afraid
then jessica added well what i got from
the story is that change is happening
everywhere and that i will do better
when i can adjust to it quickly
i remember years ago when our company
was selling our encyclopedia as a set of
more than 20 books
one person tried to tell us that we
should put our whole encyclopedia on a
single computer disc and sell it for a
fraction of the cost
it would be easier to update would cost
us so much less to manufacture and so
many more people could afford it
but we all resisted
why did you resist
nathan asked
because we believed then that the
backbone of our business was our large
sales force who called on people door to
door keeping our sales force depended on
the big commissions they earned from the
high price of our product
we had been doing this successfully for
a long time and thought it would go on
forever
laura said maybe that's what it meant in
the story about him and hoss arrogance
of success
they didn't notice they needed to change
what had once been working
nathan said so you thought your old
cheese was your only cheese
yes and we wanted to hang on to it
when i think back on what happened to us
i see that it's not just that they
move the cheese but that the cheese has
a life of its own and eventually runs
out
anyway we didn't change but a competitor
did in our sales fell badly
we've been going through a difficult
time
now another big technological change is
happening in the industry and no one at
the company seems to want to deal with
it
it doesn't look good
i think i could be out of a job soon
it's maze time
carlos called out
everyone laughed including jessica
carlos turned to jessica and said it's
good that you can laugh at yourself
frank offered that's what slash got out
of the story
i tend to take myself too seriously
i noticed how hot changed when he could
finally laugh at himself and that what
he was doing
no wonder he was called hall
the group groaned at the obvious play on
words
angela asked do you think that him ever
changed and found new cheese
elaine said i think he did
i don't corey said
some people never change and they pay a
price for it
i see people like him in my medical
practice
they feel entitled to their
cheese
they feel like victims when it's taken
away and blame others
they get sicker than people who let go
and move on
then nathan said quietly as though he
was talking to himself i guess the
question is what do we need to let go of
and what do we need to move on to
no one said anything for a while
i must admit nathan said i saw what was
happening with stores like ours in other
parts of the country but i hoped it
wouldn't affect us
i guess it's a lot better to initiate
change while you can than it is to try
to react and adjust to it
maybe we should move our own cheese
what do you mean
frank asked
nathan answered i can't help but wonder
where we would be today if we had sold
the real estate under all our old stores
and built one great modern store to
compete with the best of them
laura said maybe that's what ha meant
when he wrote on the wall savor the
adventure and move with the cheese
frank said i think something shouldn't
change
for example i want to hold on to my
basic values
but i realize now that i would be better
off if i had moved with the cheese a lot
sooner in my life
well michael it was a nice little story
richard the class skeptic said but how
did you actually put it into use in your
company
the group didn't know it yet but richard
was experiencing some changes himself
recently separated from his wife he was
now trying to balance his career with
raising his teenagers
michael replied you know i thought my
job was just to manage the daily
problems as they came up when what i
should have been doing was looking ahead
and paying attention to where we were
going
and boy did i manage those problems 24
hours a day
i wasn't a lot of fun to be around
i was in a rat race and i couldn't get
out
laura said so you were managing when you
needed to be leading
exactly michael said
then when i heard the story of who moved
my cheese i realized my job was to paint
a picture of new cheese that we
would all want to pursue so we could
enjoy changing and succeeding whether it
was at work or in life
nathan asked what did you do at work
w.e.l when i asked people in our company
who they were in the story i saw we had
every one of the four characters in our
organization
i came to see that the sniffs scurries
hems and haws each needed to be treated
differently
our sniffs could sniff out changes in
the marketplace so they helped us update
our corporate vision
they were encouraged to identify how the
changes could result in new products and
services our customers would want
the sniffs loved it and told us they
enjoyed working in a place that
recognized change and adapted in time
our scurries liked to get things done so
they were encouraged to take actions
and he eventually got a better deal
that's what i want to do more often
frank grinned
so even hems can sometimes see the
advantage of changing
carlos laughed like the advantage of
keeping their jobs
angela added or even getting a good
raise
richard who had been frowning during the
discussion said my manager's been
telling me our company needs to change
i think what she's really telling me is
that slash need to but i haven't wanted
to hear it
i guess i never really knew what the new
cheese was that she was trying to move
us to
or how i could gain from it
a slight smile crossed richard's face as
he said i must admit i like this idea of
seeing new cheese and imagining yourself
enjoying it
it lightens everything up
when you see how it can make things
better you get more interested in making
the change happen
maybe i could use this in my personal
life he added
my children seem to think that nothing
in their lives should ever change
i guess they're acting like him they're
angry
they're probably afraid of what the
future holds
maybe i haven't painted a realistic
picture of new cheese for them
probably because i don't see it myself
the group was quiet as several people
thought about their own lives
well jessica said most people here have
been talking about jobs but as i
listened to the story i also thought
about my personal life
i think my current relationship is old
cheese that has some pretty serious mold
on it
corey laughed in agreement
me too
i probably need to let go of a bad
relationship
angela countered or perhaps the old
cheese is just old behavior
what
we really need to let go of is the
behavior that is the cause of our bad
relationships
and then move on to a better way of
thinking and acting
ouch
corey reacted
good point
the new cheese is a new relationship
with the same person
richard said i'm beginning to think
there is more to this than i thought
i like the idea of letting go of old
behavior instead of letting go of the
relationship
repeating the same behavior will just
get you the same results
as far as work goes maybe instead of
changing jobs i should be changing the
way i am doing my job
i'd probably have a better position by
now if i did
then becky who lived in another city but
had returned for the reunion said
as i was listening to the story and to
everyone's comments here i've had to
laugh at myself
i've been like him for so long hemming
and hawing and afraid of change
i didn't realize how many other people
did this as well
i'm afraid i've passed it on to my
children without even knowing it
as i think about it i realize change
really can lead you to a new and better
place although you're afraid it won't at
the time
i remember a time when our son was a
sophomore in high school
my husband's job required us to move
from illinois to vermont and our son was
upset because he had to leave his
friends
he was a star swimmer in the high school
in vermont had no swim team
so he was angry with us for making him
move
as it turned out he fell in love with
the vermont mountains took up ski ng
skied on his college team and now lives
happily in colorado
if we had all enjoyed this cheese story
together over a cup of hot chocolate we
could have saved our family a lot of
stress
jessica said i'm going home to tell my
family this story
i'll ask my children who they think i am
sniff scurry him or ha and who they feel
they are
we could talk about what we feel our
family's old cheese is and what our new
cheese could be
that's a good idea richard said
surprising everyone even himself
frank then commented i think i'm going
to be more like ha and move with the
cheese and enjoy it
and i'm going to pass the story along to
my friends who are worried about leaving
the military and what the change might
mean to them
it could lead to some interesting
discussions
michael said well that's how we improved
our business
we had several discussions about what we
got from the chi story and how we could
apply it to our situation
it was great because we had language
that was fun for us to use to talk about
how we were dealing with change
it was very
effective especially as it spread deeper
into the company
nathan asked what do you mean by deeper
well the further we went into our
organization the more people we found
who felt they had less power
they were understandably more afraid of
what the change imposed from above might
do to them
so they resisted change
in short a change imposed is a change
opposed
but when the chi story was shared with
literally everyone in our organization
it helped us change the way we looked at
change
it helped everyone laugh or at least
smile at their old fears and want to
move on
i only wished i'd heard the cheese story
sooner michael added how come
carlos asked
because by the time we got around to
addressing the changes our business had
already fallen off so badly that we had
to let people go as i said earlier
including some good friends
it was hard on all of us
however those who stayed and most of
those who left said the chi story helped
them see things differently and
eventually cope better
those who had to go out and look for a
new job said it was hard at first but
recalling the story was a great help to
them
angela asked what helped the most
michael replied after they got past
their fear they told me the best thing
was realizing that there was new cheese
out there just waiting to be found
they said holding a picture of new
cheese in their minds seeing themselves
doing well in a new job made them feel
better and help them do better in job
interviews
several got better jobs
laura asked what about the people who
remained in your company
well michael said instead of complaining
about the changes that were happening
people now said they just moved our
cheese
let's look for the new cheese
it saved a lot of time and reduced
stress
before long the people who had been
resisting saw the advantage of changing
they even helped bring about change
corey said why do you think they changed
they changed after the peer pressure in
our company changed
he asked what happens in most
organizations you've been in when a
change is announced by top management
do most people say the change is a great
idea or a bad idea
a bad idea frank answered
yes michael agreed
why
carlo said because people want things to
stay the same and they think the change
will be bad for them
when one person says the change is a bad
idea others say the same
yes they may not real why feel that way
michael said but they agree in order to
fit in
that's the sort of peer pressure that
fights change in any organization
becky asked so how were things different
after people heard the chi story
michael said simply the peer pressure
changed
no one wanted to look like him
everyone laughed
they wanted to sniff out the changes
ahead of time and scurry into action
rather than get hemmed in and be left
behind
nathan said that's a good point
no one in our company would want to look
like him
they might even change
why didn't you tell us the story at our
last reunion
this could work
michael said it does work
it works best of course when everyone in
your organization knows the story
whether it is in a large corporation a
small business or your family
because an organization can only change
when enough people in a change
then he offered one last thought
when we saw how well it worked for us we
passed the story along to people we
wanted to do business with knowing they
were also dealing with change
we suggested we might be there new
cheese that is better partners for them
to succeed with
it led to new business
that gave jessica several ideas and
reminded her that she had some early
sales calls in the morning
she looked at her watch and said well
it's time for me to leave this cheese
station and find some new cheese
the group laughed and began saying their
goodbyes
many of them wanted to continue the
conversation but needed to leave
as they left they thanked michael again
he said i'm very glad you found the
story so useful and i hope that you will
have the opportunity to share it with
others soon
the end